Caption: so my name is Mike Amundsen as you've
Caption: already heard I this is my first visit
Caption: to Perth I'm very excited my first visit
Caption: to
Caption: bankwest it's been an amazing several
Caption: days the kind of work they're doing here
Caption: is really quite incredible so it's very
Caption: exciting bankwest has been a really
Caption: great host I come I live in Kentucky in
Caption: the United States how many people have
Caption: been to Kentucky one person me anyway
Caption: what do we know about Kentucky chicken
Caption: chicken right chicken I'm sorry I'm
Caption: really sorry about that but yeah chicken
Caption: next what else Bourbon my favorite part
Caption: horses too but you know that's another
Caption: thing we race a little bit in Kentucky
Caption: but bourbon is really the thing the only
Caption: problem is I'm I really like bourbon a
Caption: lot and so I get to be like kind of a
Caption: bourbon snob like if that's possible I
Caption: think it is but then that means it's
Caption: always really expensive here right so I
Caption: really want no no I want that other
Caption: thing that's like really rare in us and
Caption: yeah it got shipped all the way here so
Caption: it's really expensive but I enjoy it a
Caption: lot so this is me this is how you find
Caption: me this is the best way to figure out
Caption: where I am is to actually just look on
Caption: Twitter or github and LinkedIn I travel
Caption: a lot so I'm here this week I landed on
Caption: Sunday I'll leave on Saturday to fly to
Caption: Lyon France for the web conference world
Caption: wide web conference be there for a week
Caption: I get to stay home for a week and then I
Caption: fly to South America for a week then I
Caption: go to Copenhagen for a week that's kind
Caption: of my life last year I was traveling
Caption: somewhere 40 weeks last year that's too
Caption: much I'm cutting back going for like 35
Caption: I promise but I get to meet so many
Caption: really interesting people in so many so
Caption: many fantastic places it's a great job I
Caption: work in a group that's called the API
Caption: Academy I'm just gonna talk about them
Caption: briefly because they co-sponsored a lot
Caption: of my travel API Academy is a group of
Caption: sort of researchers they sometimes use
Caption: the word thought leaders that are based
Caption: in lots of locations in London and
Caption: Zurich and Silicon Valley and Vancouver
Caption: and I'm the one that's in Kentucky and
Caption: we travel around all of them travel
Caption: around like I do we get to meet
Caption: organisations collect up ideas and share
Caption: that back the last big project we
Caption: completed was a book on micro services
Caption: about a year ago where we got a chance
Caption: to talk to companies like Netflix in
Caption: Google and Amazon and SoundCloud and
Caption: uber and all these other organizations
Caption: to figure out what they're doing and how
Caption: they're doing it so that's a chance to
Caption: share that so we have a website if you
Caption: just look up API Academy you'll find it
Caption: so it's a great place to collect
Caption: information and a lot of the things that
Caption: I'm going to share today are things that
Caption: we've learned in lots of other companies
Caption: around the world as well so this is my
Caption: chance to share with you and this is a
Caption: chance for us to just kind of talk so I
Caption: wanted to do something a little bit
Caption: unusual this isn't going to be a really
Caption: techy talk it's not going to be I don't
Caption: have any URLs or anything like this in
Caption: it but a lot of people that I work with
Caption: are trying to figure out how to create
Caption: great api's how to create great
Caption: interfaces to their business to their
Caption: services some of the customers I work
Caption: with are actually in competition in a
Caption: market like in third parties to attract
Caption: developers to their api's it's very much
Caption: a market driven business so they're
Caption: trying to figure out how to do that so
Caption: they talk a lot about what's good what's
Caption: great what's useable what's functional
Caption: how can we make this better and I
Caption: remember a book from a long time ago
Caption: about business management called good to
Caption: great when these characteristics that
Caption: James Collins had about what companies
Caption: are great and why they're great how do
Caption: they get from just being good to
Caption: actually being bad
Caption: and I thought well I'd like to go back
Caption: and relook at those things and see if
Caption: those kinds of lessons those kinds of
Caption: characteristics can maybe be applied in
Caption: the same kind of way so so this is this
Caption: is James Collins
Caption: James has written several books James
Caption: looks pretty severe and most of his
Caption: publicity photos but he is apparently a
Caption: pretty friendly guy and he spent a bunch
Caption: of time he's from Harvard Business
Caption: School and all these other things and he
Caption: spent a lot of time on this idea about
Caption: what is it about certain characteristics
Caption: of a business there's certain
Caption: characteristics of a group of people
Caption: that actually make it rise above in some
Caption: kind of way so he wrote this book and
Caption: you were at this book I think was in the
Caption: 80s I can't quite remember but he wrote
Caption: about this idea of how you transition
Caption: from good to great how you get from one
Caption: place to another what would help people
Caption: kind of identify whether or not you're
Caption: actually on the path you're actually
Caption: gonna pull this off the secondary lesson
Caption: in his book there was a little bit more
Caption: concerning it's how most people don't
Caption: make it so what are those unique things
Caption: that actually make it possible so I
Caption: figured out how can we do that can we
Caption: apply some of the same ideas to this
Caption: world of api's in many ways many of my
Caption: customers for for them api SAR a product
Caption: api's are a marketplace a PR are a
Caption: business imperative they're not just a
Caption: back-office element they're not just a
Caption: way to reduce cost they're a way to
Caption: actually create opportunity so it would
Caption: seem to make sense if we can apply some
Caption: of these same ideas so Collins has these
Caption: things he calls the seven principles
Caption: some of these may sound familiar you may
Caption: recognize them from some other source
Caption: I'm not gonna go through them too much
Caption: in detail but he has this notion of
Caption: level 5 leaders this idea of you first
Caption: figure out who you're dealing with and
Caption: then what you're gonna do you confront
Caption: brutal facts which I thought there's a
Caption: really interesting one you're actually
Caption: brutally honest with yourself and
Caption: everyone else and that's how you
Caption: actually start to get ahead
Caption: this is an interesting story that's
Caption: called a hedgehog concept it's a little
Caption: bit like the tortoise and hare story the
Caption: head truckin and the Fox is an old tale
Caption: and it turns out the Hedgehog always
Caption: wins the hedgehog Hedgehog always
Caption: outsmarts the Fox and why is that and
Caption: it's because the Hedgehog has a real
Caption: commitment because if he loses he dies
Caption: he's like it were got a real passion for
Caption: success a culture of discipline this is
Caption: a pattern that I see in lots of
Caption: companies that I visit the ones that are
Caption: really good they're they're really good
Caption: at doing the little things are really
Caption: good at doing the mundane things and
Caption: we'll talk about that I love this idea
Caption: using technology to accelerate growth
Caption: for us API space or in the IT space we
Caption: would say oh sure of course you would
Caption: but he's got a really interesting point
Caption: of view on this which basically says
Caption: using technology just for technology's
Caption: sake is a disaster is a big mistake and
Caption: it's hard for us sometimes to know
Caption: especially when we're in IT to actually
Caption: tell our business management or tell our
Caption: leadership to say you know what it's not
Caption: really a good idea to convert that or to
Caption: spend time on that we should leave that
Caption: alone leave that legacy thing alone we
Caption: should do this over here instead a lot
Caption: of times if we're given an opportunity
Caption: to rebuild the same house again we'd
Caption: love to do it right
Caption: matter of fact what we first do is we'd
Caption: actually destroy the old one sort of
Caption: like ghosts oviya they could never
Caption: existed that old version never existed
Caption: we just replaced a brand new one right
Caption: we don't like a lot of history a lot of
Caption: times and then the last one he talks
Caption: about the flywheel this comes up in a
Caption: couple of other different cases the idea
Caption: of once you get started once you get
Caption: rolling even if you can move it a little
Caption: bit it gets easier and easier and easier
Caption: and easier so this flywheel concept
Caption: comes in really handy as well so all
Caption: these things about leadership and focus
Caption: and discipline and and all these other
Caption: things all lead to what means greatness
Caption: in in Collins eyes so
Caption: I thought maybe we can talk about this
Caption: from just an amp in API perspective what
Caption: do we need how does it work what does
Caption: that look like and the first thing I
Caption: think about is developers we hear these
Caption: stories about 10x developers or
Caption: full-stack developers or hero developers
Caption: or all these other things in in the we
Caption: have a kind of a romantic notion about
Caption: some developer that spends like they
Caption: have no personal life they do everything
Caption: at work and they're amazing people
Caption: nobody understands how she pulls it off
Caption: but this stuff always works and it turns
Caption: out that's not really a good path to
Caption: greatness it actually is a path to
Caption: somebody getting burned out a company
Caption: having a huge dependence on just a few
Caption: heroic people yet and those people often
Caption: end up leaving because they don't have a
Caption: balanced life so what is a good
Caption: developer and this level-5 thing is
Caption: actually pretty handy I like the way
Caption: Collins talks about what level 5
Caption: developers are in essence he talks about
Caption: he talks about them as leaders but he
Caption: says they're people who are humble but
Caption: driven to do what's best for the company
Caption: there are lots of people that I get a
Caption: chance to meet and talk to who work in
Caption: these IT programs these capi programs
Caption: and they're really smart and they're
Caption: really really intelligent and they're
Caption: also incredibly generous and that
Caption: usually is a sign that they work in a
Caption: community where that kind of behavior is
Caption: is promoted and they usually build some
Caption: of the greatest stuff they just work
Caption: really hard and they don't look for a
Caption: lot of attention and that's pretty
Caption: amazing
Caption: when Collins talks about it he talks
Caption: about it as sort of your role in the
Caption: organization that in the beginning like
Caption: the level one is just it's a capable
Caption: individual this somebody does their job
Caption: well know what's going on keep up with
Caption: things that's really great at the next
Caption: level is somebody who contributes to the
Caption: team often it gets characterized as
Caption: helping the team actually look great
Caption: like by that's a great team why and I
Caption: wonder wonder what's going on there at
Caption: the next at the next point in Collins
Caption: story is this idea of actually being a
Caption: good
Caption: manager a good group manager you
Caption: actually not only help the team look
Caption: good but you actually help the team get
Caption: better you hope the team figure out how
Caption: to how to be really effective and that's
Caption: sort of the next level you actually help
Caption: more than just your team but maybe your
Caption: division or your group of people and
Caption: then finally at a point where you're
Caption: really able to help the organization
Caption: improve in lots of different ways and
Caption: I've seen developers like this too at
Caption: each stage of this process and usually
Caption: the things they produce as they get
Caption: better as they get higher up in this
Caption: sort of stack that Collins talks about
Caption: the focus goes less and less on their
Caption: own interests or their own skills and
Caption: more and more on their customers or
Caption: their stakeholders or some other aspect
Caption: one of the keys to making something
Caption: great a helping organization get to be
Caption: great it's figuring out who your
Caption: audience is what it is what is it that
Caption: they really want what is it that they
Caption: really need and there are lots of
Caption: organizations that are pretty good at
Caption: this one company in particular that in
Caption: IT space that has a lot of api's that's
Caption: pretty interesting is Spotify is anybody
Caption: heard of the Spotify company they spend
Caption: a great deal of time focusing on how
Caption: they can help their individuals move up
Caption: that kind of stack they don't they don't
Caption: talk about level one through five liters
Caption: but they talk about this ability to
Caption: contribute and in their leadership
Caption: material they talk a lot about being
Caption: humble as a leader so I think they're a
Caption: really great example if you're
Caption: interested in how to build a community
Caption: of developers and not just in your own
Caption: team but cross team Spotify is a great
Caption: example and I think Spotify has a really
Caption: good reputation as a good IT company a
Caption: good product company and they do a lot
Caption: of really interesting things in their in
Caption: their in their program so I would
Caption: encourage you to check out Spotify
Caption: there's lots of stuff online if you just
Caption: say scaling Spotify there's a series of
Caption: articles about how they run their
Caption: organization how they get people to work
Caption: in teams so one of the things that that
Caption: Colin says about this particular aspect
Caption: is it's about resolve and like
Caption: determination like I'm gonna do what the
Caption: company needs
Caption: and I think all of us have probably
Caption: experienced at one time or another
Caption: that you've got the company in mind but
Caption: maybe some of your colleagues some of
Caption: your peers don't quite know that and you
Caption: have to kind of press on anyway it gets
Caption: frustrating when people don't listen you
Caption: know you're trying to help but you can't
Caption: quite get through and the people who end
Caption: up really good at this are able to get
Caption: past that frustration and keep at it I
Caption: was having a conversation with somebody
Caption: that I'd met a few years ago when I was
Caption: down here and we're talking about how
Caption: things get popular and things change and
Caption: and people move on but there's always
Caption: this feeling like yeah that's okay
Caption: they'll be back we'll have the same set
Caption: of problems I'll be here I'll be ready
Caption: to help so with that that's a really big
Caption: part of it and that leads to the second
Caption: thing one another pattern that Collins
Caption: talks about is he in his list he says
Caption: first who then what and that's a that's
Caption: a really important rule and the way he
Caption: describes it is get the right people on
Caption: the bus first then figure out where
Caption: you're gonna go
Caption: so really it's this notion that the
Caption: people you have is actually more
Caption: important than the direction you think
Caption: you want to go and in fact the people
Caption: you have will affect your journey how
Caption: you're gonna get there and that's a
Caption: really powerful thing it's very similar
Caption: to the kind of things that Spotify talks
Caption: about and a great a company that's great
Caption: at this get the right people on the bus
Caption: pattern is Netflix so Netflix has this
Caption: reputation of spending a lot of time
Caption: they say hiring from the top of the
Caption: barrel finding the right people and so
Caption: they had this thing about if somebody if
Caption: you're if you it from a manager
Caption: standpoint if somebody was leaving would
Caption: you really fight to keep them and if the
Caption: answer is no and Netflix they say well
Caption: then you should probably get that help
Caption: that person find another place in the
Caption: organization because they're not vital
Caption: to what you're doing
Caption: find people get the right people and
Caption: then they'll help you figure out where
Caption: to go
Caption: at Netflix they also tell their managers
Caption: your job is not to tell them what to do
Caption: your job is to give them direction give
Caption: them some help carry water ask them what
Caption: they need because they're the experts
Caption: they're the ones who know what to do so
Caption: that's that same idea first who then
Caption: what and a big part of that Collin says
Caption: is vision you need to give your smart
Caption: people a vision they'd be happy to work
Caption: on something powerful and fantastic if
Caption: they had a sense that they knew where
Caption: they were headed so so Netflix is a
Caption: great example of this kind of element
Caption: and Netflix has even to be more explicit
Caption: about it their last release of their
Caption: whole API set was actually designed to
Caption: improve the experience for users on
Caption: every single device they used to have a
Caption: general API that all the devices use ps2
Caption: and Xbox and Android and the browser and
Caption: iPhone they all use the same API but
Caption: Netflix realized that you didn't have a
Caption: really good experience and everyone it
Caption: was all kind of generic it was kind of
Caption: hard to get each one of those to really
Caption: shine so they went out and they built a
Caption: custom built interface API for every
Caption: single device sometimes even different
Caption: versions of the same device in order to
Caption: make sure that that API experience was
Caption: exactly fitting to the experience of
Caption: programming on an iOS device or
Caption: programming on the ps2 they actually
Caption: created what they called experience
Caption: api's because they were really focused
Caption: on this vision about how to make sure
Caption: that they got just the right kind of
Caption: experience on every device so that
Caption: really helps a lot
Caption: confronting the brutal confronting
Caption: brutal facts this is one that's really
Caption: hard and it's a great differentiator in
Caption: the book he talks about a thing called
Caption: the Stockdale paradox I'm not sure if
Caption: for a lot of people in the room would
Caption: actually know who James Stockdale was he
Caption: was actually a Vietnam War prisoner of
Caption: war and he was in there for quite a long
Caption: time like seven years I think to say six
Caption: or seven years
Caption: and he kept saying that he in order to
Caption: keep going in order to keep his spirits
Caption: up he had to have faith that one day
Caption: he'd be released but he couldn't let
Caption: that faith blind him from the brutal
Caption: fact that he is currently a prisoner so
Caption: as long as he confronted the brutal
Caption: facts every day he could cope but he
Caption: said there were people who kept saying
Caption: well next day we'll get released or next
Caption: day we'll get released and they would
Caption: get crushed over and over again so
Caption: confronting the brutal facts actually
Caption: gives you power it gives you this
Caption: ability to do something about it if you
Caption: just ignore if you just look at the
Caption: bright side all the time it doesn't work
Caption: I think one of the best examples of
Caption: confronting the brutal facts came from a
Caption: sort of an odd case a random case by the
Caption: I got a name is Steve Yeager is anybody
Caption: heard of the yeah mm oh the ug memo this
Caption: is a great experience Steve Yeager was
Caption: hired away from Amazon to go work at
Caption: Google and when he came to Google Steve
Caption: said that he was absolutely appalled at
Caption: what he didn't find what he thought was
Caption: going on and he his experience at Amazon
Caption: had told him that he should expect
Caption: certain things that weren't there so and
Caption: then when the first week or two first
Caption: couple of weeks he was there he sat down
Caption: and wrote this rant wrote this memo
Caption: about how Google is in big trouble
Caption: unless they start changing things you've
Caption: got to face facts
Caption: you're gonna have your lunch handed to
Caption: you by Amazon if you don't do the
Caption: following things and let me give you
Caption: some examples the funny thing was Steve
Caption: had only been there a few weeks he
Caption: didn't quite understand how we in her
Caption: office services work and what he did is
Caption: he wrote it and clicked and sent it to
Caption: his public Google+ page so everybody had
Caption: to see what was even better is Google
Caption: didn't fire him all right they said you
Caption: know what you're right
Caption: you don't have to tell everybody else
Caption: that but you're right
Caption: so and Steve has done this a couple of
Caption: times before Steve is now since left
Caption: Google I I can't remember where he's
Caption: gone next I don't know if anybody can
Caption: remind me I think it was in the last
Caption: year where is it
Caption: what's it he's working on a game yeah so
Caption: even even it was he was leaving he wrote
Caption: another one of these messages to the
Caption: company about what he likes about it
Caption: what he doesn't like about it and he was
Caption: also pretty brutal in that process but
Caption: Steve has done a great job of making
Caption: that part of his superpower part of his
Caption: character and it's become one of the
Caption: things that helped the projects that he
Caption: worked on at Google get really really
Caption: good because it's really based on this
Caption: idea that unless you're brutally honest
Caption: you're really not going to be able to
Caption: make good decisions you're gonna be sort
Caption: of living in this dream kind of world
Caption: so creating great interfaces great api's
Caption: great products for companies really has
Caption: a lot to do with this notion of being
Caption: really honest so the one that's most
Caption: peculiar to me in in reading Jim's book
Caption: is this idea of the Hedgehog so there's
Caption: a story about this Hedgehog and this Fox
Caption: and that the Hedgehog is able to
Caption: outsmart the Fox and it's primarily
Caption: because the Hedgehog has everything to
Caption: lose and the Fox has not much to gain in
Caption: their in their fight between them so the
Caption: way that Jim talks about it he says
Caption: there's this confluence of things what
Caption: is it that you're really passionate
Caption: about what do you think you can be best
Caption: at in the world not just best at in this
Caption: neighborhood but what's gonna make you
Caption: really powerful really unique and what's
Caption: the driving resource what's the driving
Caption: source of what you do this is a great
Caption: way to think about products this is a
Caption: great way to think about what your
Caption: organization has what do you pack what
Caption: is your organization passionate about
Caption: what do you do that nobody else does and
Caption: paying attention to who pays your bills
Caption: how this is really gonna gonna pay off
Caption: in the end
Caption: and he talks about this sort of
Caption: confluence of these three things is
Caption: actually that sweet spot if you can
Caption: operate inside that zone nobody can beat
Caption: you one of the things we learned is we
Caption: talked to lots of different companies
Caption: about how they decide what's important
Caption: in how they invest their time and energy
Caption: one of the things we saw over and over
Caption: again as companies like Netflix and
Caption: Amazon in Google and Microsoft and
Caption: Facebook they almost always have some
Caption: investment in creating like an internal
Caption: set of tools or an internal set of
Caption: processes that really play on their
Caption: biggest value or their biggest
Caption: superpower their their biggest passion
Caption: or principle at Netflix the most
Caption: important thing for Netflix is that the
Caption: system never go down that when you're
Caption: watching a show you never get
Caption: interrupted it doesn't stop you don't
Caption: get the little buffer thing that's the
Caption: most important principle for them and
Caption: they'll do just about anything to pull
Caption: that off in order to make that work they
Caption: have to have a super resilient system
Caption: they have to have a system that's even
Caption: smart enough that when something doesn't
Caption: quite work in one region because they
Caption: use Amazon's regions if it doesn't work
Caption: here in Australia then they'll switch to
Caption: this to Singapore servers to actually
Caption: deliver
Caption: deliver streaming video here in on this
Caption: continent so they work really hard to
Caption: make their system reliable so they
Caption: invested thousands of hours I suspect
Caption: tens of hundreds of thousands of dollars
Caption: you know in a way to make sure that
Caption: their system is reliable does anybody
Caption: know what that big investment is what
Caption: did they build what did what was it
Caption: chaos monkey and chaos army they built
Caption: all this software to to make sure that
Caption: they build better software and that's
Caption: why they're so great at this because
Caption: that's what they did at Amazon they have
Caption: a different value but Amazon their value
Caption: is they want to create as many products
Caption: as possible minimum viable products and
Caption: get them up and launched and kill off
Caption: the ones that don't make sense they want
Caption: to increase their averages now a lot
Caption: more tries means they could find more
Caption: products so they spend thousands of
Caption: hours and lots and lots of money on a
Caption: system where if I get an idea I come
Caption: into the office
Caption: Monday I can press a button that can
Caption: fill out a form and I get a new product
Caption: build I get a couple of ec2 instances I
Caption: get a Giri list I get a build pipeline
Caption: there's a little mailing alert list
Caption: that's set up all the things up
Caption: templates all this stuff ready for me to
Caption: go in a repo and then the last step it
Caption: tells my boss and I love that that's the
Caption: last step right one of the things I
Caption: think we learned from from Amazon I
Caption: think was from somebody at Amazon is if
Caption: you want to be great stop asking for
Caption: permission right so they build their
Caption: system so that if you've got a great
Caption: idea we want you to start on it right
Caption: away and just let me know now eventually
Caption: if I do this a few times and not much is
Caption: happening like I start a new one every
Caption: week my boss might come to my cube and
Caption: she'll say you're gonna complete
Caption: something a unit and now so that's what
Caption: they do right but I don't have to ask to
Caption: start do we know this Etsy this Etsy
Caption: shop the sort of online store for
Caption: crafters at Etsy they're super power is
Caption: releasing they released about 40 times a
Caption: day to production that's pretty amazing
Caption: and what they did is they built this
Caption: entire system to let that let just about
Caption: anybody in their company released a
Caption: production they have that sort of a
Caption: protocol on a simple change like maybe I
Caption: need to get at least one other person to
Caption: sign off and agree and then we need to
Caption: run the tests there's a thing called
Caption: writing an assertion like how this is
Caption: going to help and then that's all
Caption: automated and eventually it gets sent
Caption: out to some small part of the or of my
Caption: user base they segment the base but
Caption: again they that's their superpower so
Caption: they spent time on that so every one of
Caption: us work at a company where there is
Caption: actually this sort of super thing that
Caption: would make us great and companies that
Caption: spend time and money making that
Caption: powerful making that easy for everyone
Caption: and they're actually engaging in this
Caption: Hedgehog idea a company that I think is
Caption: pretty good at this is a company called
Caption: Twilio Twilio is their only product is
Caption: an API and they that it's basically SMS
Caption: messaging or now they think they do some
Caption: voice and some other things and what's
Caption: cool about Twilio is toyou doesn't
Caption: actually send any SMS messages they
Caption: purchase service from AT&T and other
Caption: phone companies in
Caption: Telstra and so and so far they purchased
Caption: that what they built is a great API and
Caption: they also know that developers are their
Caption: secret sauce so their whole program the
Caption: way they talk about it is that you can
Caption: do whatever you want to do without a lot
Caption: of effort and we're here to make that
Caption: possible for you that's sort of their
Caption: power the whole Twilio the whole idea
Caption: about how they design their api is and
Caption: how they document them and all that has
Caption: this personality of like we're gonna
Caption: help you with your passion and I've
Caption: worked with some Twilio evangelist in
Caption: the past and they have that same kind of
Caption: passion about how what they can do what
Caption: they do can help us in so many other
Caption: ways so I think they do a really good
Caption: job at that
Caption: and it's really in order to stay on top
Caption: you really need to be working in that
Caption: little passion zone it might you might
Caption: turn out to be really good at something
Caption: better than most of the peers around you
Caption: inside an organization but if you're not
Caption: really passionate about it it's possible
Caption: that somebody else will come along that
Caption: will be even more interested in it so
Caption: passion is really a key driver for
Caption: reaching this greatness and the other
Caption: side of that passion that willingness to
Caption: take time or that that that willingness
Caption: to dig into it is this notion of
Caption: discipline and we've seen a lot of this
Caption: Collins calls it a culture of discipline
Caption: this ability to get in there and do the
Caption: things that you need to do every single
Caption: day he has the example of called rinsing
Caption: the cottage cheese if you really want to
Caption: make really good cottage cheese it turns
Caption: out there's this step where you have to
Caption: rinse it a lot to get all of the
Caption: bitterness out and actually get it to
Caption: you know taste really good and fresh I'm
Caption: not really a fan of cottage cheese but I
Caption: understand the concept but it turns out
Caption: it's a dull and boring and annoying and
Caption: dirty and and yucky job but if you want
Caption: to be great you have to do that and
Caption: that's a really big part of doing things
Caption: well is doing the stuff that isn't it
Caption: isn't romantic that isn't exciting that
Caption: isn't interesting but you do it over and
Caption: over I worked with a gentleman for a
Caption: while by the name of Steve collab Nick
Caption: Steve is a great evangelist a great
Caption: speaker on api's and he's have done
Caption: involved in a handful of standards
Caption: he worked for a company for balanced
Caption: payments for a while and he helped build
Caption: their API program and he said the most
Caption: important thing that he was able to do
Caption: there is help them figure out how to how
Caption: to be disciplined how to do things over
Caption: and over and over again he kind of
Caption: invented his own sort of test driven
Caption: development notion and sort of infused
Caption: it not just into the way that they wrote
Caption: tests or wrote code but actually the way
Caption: they they deployed their entire system
Caption: and he got everybody really excited
Caption: about paying attention to the small
Caption: details and doing it over and over and
Caption: over again one of the things that that
Caption: he talks about is the idea of is making
Caption: the boring stuff easy so you can get on
Caption: to something else but he was he was
Caption: really really good at that and balanced
Caption: payments I'm not sure if they're
Caption: actually I think they got purchased but
Caption: they were one of the first sort of open
Caption: banking API or open money management
Caption: api's about three or four years ago
Caption: before it got to be a big thing and they
Caption: sort of led the way on how that's done
Caption: and the way Collins talks about this is
Caption: when you take that discipline and you
Caption: marry that to that passion and that sort
Caption: of creative idea then you can really
Caption: start creating something great and I
Caption: think balanced payment did that really
Caption: really well I think it's the same kind
Caption: of thing that Twilio does they're great
Caption: at details as well so creating something
Caption: great is often just talking about
Caption: discipline and then there's this idea of
Caption: technology accelerators now from Collins
Caption: standpoint in the late 80s technology
Caption: was this sort of extra thing it was not
Caption: really infused with the same kind of
Caption: purpose and meaning that we have today I
Caption: have a great story uh I think Gregor
Caption: hoppy will be here soon he'll be coming
Caption: back here soon
Caption: Gregor had moved from Google to Allianz
Caption: insurance and he said he was kind of
Caption: startled at Allianz he said they would
Caption: be talking about something that we're
Caption: gonna work on a new banking product or a
Caption: new entry there was an insurance company
Caption: and somebody would say at Allianz you
Caption: know we should go talk to IT about that
Caption: and Gregor said you know at Google
Caption: nobody says that
Caption: they don't say we should go talk to IT
Caption: why is that because Google is IT right
Caption: so Google IT is the product IT is not
Caption: this added thing it's not this extra
Caption: thing we don't apply technology to
Caption: whatever the idea is Google is
Caption: technology so I think Colin's a view on
Caption: this is actually pretty good so he talks
Caption: about using technology to be the
Caption: accelerator pick your technologies so
Caption: they get you further on to where you
Caption: want to be and what you want to do in
Caption: sort of the back story er the hidden
Caption: message of this is don't pick technology
Caption: just for technology's sake don't become
Caption: a camp follower don't just pick the
Caption: latest thing because it's the latest
Caption: thing figure out what it is you really
Caption: need you really want and do that and
Caption: that can be challenging for us who are
Caption: in the business of knowing what the
Caption: latest and the greatest is it turns out
Caption: that all the newest stuff is not always
Caption: applicable to all the things that we
Caption: might do and maybe just a few teams need
Caption: to be focusing on graph QL and the rest
Caption: of the company needs to be focusing on
Caption: you know rest style or crud style maybe
Caption: we have to maintain a really important
Caption: investment in our soap services because
Caption: that's where most of our partners are
Caption: using the technology that's appropriate
Caption: in order to meet the needs of that
Caption: particular audience can be really the
Caption: the best way to go and that's a lot of
Caption: what Amazon is like from what we were
Caption: able to learn about Amazon's AWS an
Caption: internal program and their api's and how
Caption: they build it they're amazingly agnostic
Caption: about a particular technology or a
Caption: particular style of service or back-end
Caption: or open source they kind of don't care
Caption: in their organisation if your team wants
Caption: to use Kafka fine they don't want to use
Caption: it fine if you want to use some sequel
Caption: light or you want to use my sequel
Caption: that's fine if you want to use this
Caption: editor that editor all they really care
Caption: about is what comes out of the system
Caption: they say as long as your group produces
Caption: in the same interoperable format that we
Caption: have that's what they have a huge
Caption: discipline on is about the way things
Caption: work in
Caption: operably then you're just it's just fine
Caption: with us you do whatever you want to do
Caption: they don't really care so they don't
Caption: really get excited about any new thing
Caption: that comes along the other thing though
Caption: that's really interesting and this is
Caption: one of the reasons I picked they're
Caption: they're API for their gateway is they're
Caption: more than willing to try a technology
Caption: the API gateway actually uses a
Caption: messaging format called Hale or
Caption: hypertext application language has
Caption: anybody heard of hell before so Amazon
Caption: has been really willing to try something
Caption: out in matter of fact in perfect Amazon
Caption: style they had a an app streaming API it
Caption: had to do with some of their internal
Caption: management for their workspaces and some
Caption: some app space applications and when
Caption: they release that API they released it
Caption: using a traditional sort of crud style
Caption: interface and a Hal interface they
Caption: actually released it with two interfaces
Caption: and they watched to see which one people
Caption: used and how it worked and how easy they
Caption: were to maintain and what they learned
Caption: from that is that hey this is how thing
Caption: actually works pretty good so this net
Caption: this API that they released they decided
Caption: to only release with a Hal interface
Caption: right so they did a little experimenting
Caption: they got some results and they said hey
Caption: people are interested I'll use this
Caption: technology now I can I can bet that if
Caption: this doesn't work well they'll just
Caption: switch it to whatever works because
Caption: that's really what they do for them a
Caption: technology a format a library all these
Caption: other things are just an accelerator to
Caption: their real goal which is to help people
Caption: solve their problems that's what they're
Caption: passionate about the other thing that I
Caption: love this I love this line culture eats
Caption: strategy for breakfast this is actually
Caption: a version of a line from from Peter
Caption: Drucker another business management
Caption: person and he said and I love that they
Caption: added and technology for lunch right and
Caption: then you're then it actually eats the
Caption: whole thing so it's okay to use
Caption: technology as an accelerator but don't
Caption: become just the technology and here he
Caption: is he talks about a thoughtless reliance
Caption: just makes it a liability
Caption: so that's another big thing that I see
Caption: organizations struggle with and that is
Caption: well we're gonna convert a whole bunch
Caption: of things and we're gonna actually use
Caption: this brand-new open-source thing to do
Caption: all of it and that means that if the
Caption: open-source thing doesn't work out our
Caption: whole investment in that thing is not
Caption: going to work out in others they don't
Caption: decouple the technology from the goal if
Caption: we want to migrate something we're gonna
Caption: migrate it and we're gonna apply this
Caption: technology that's pretty good but if it
Caption: turns out you become stuck you can
Caption: actually bet the whole company on one
Caption: particular thing that turns out to be a
Caption: liability and that's where I was really
Caption: impressed about how Amazon would
Caption: actually use multiple pieces of
Caption: technology or multiple the samples of
Caption: this and see what's going to happen
Caption: that's really a thing that I think talks
Caption: about greatness then the last one in his
Caption: list is a thing called a flywheel
Caption: principle it has this added effect of
Caption: small initiatives of small efforts if I
Caption: push it just a little it gets easier and
Caption: easier and easier as I start to push it
Caption: until pretty soon it's easy to keep it
Caption: going it's easy to get it going really
Caption: fast most of us who work on development
Caption: we actually experience a version of this
Caption: flywheel thing in our heads right you
Caption: show up you sit down at your terminal
Caption: you clear your head you're about to get
Caption: ready it takes some time to start
Caption: reading some documentation looking at
Caption: code that you checked in yesterday maybe
Caption: some other things and then pretty soon
Caption: you start get going you sort of get into
Caption: headspace and it works really well and
Caption: you can actually be very effective at
Caption: this and things are working really
Caption: really great until somebody stops by
Caption: your cubicle right and then they break
Caption: your concentration in a second yeah
Caption: whatever bah blah blah we can do lunch
Caption: and so on so forth and then you turn
Caption: around you got to start again you know
Caption: start working up working up and working
Caption: on the finally you get into headspace
Caption: again and then the phone rings right or
Caption: something
Caption: Microsoft figured that out this out very
Caption: early on at Microsoft they had you know
Caption: hundreds and hundreds of developers and
Caption: they wanted to make sure that they could
Caption: focus and keep their focus for an
Caption: extended period of time
Caption: so they built buildings where everyone
Caption: had an office with a door and it's just
Caption: I've been here it's just rows and rows
Caption: of these tiny little offices with the
Caption: same door and there's there's actually a
Caption: piece of you know a small glass window
Caption: on the side the door is solid and it's
Caption: just row upon row upon row and you can
Caption: get lost it's like it's it's really kind
Caption: of kind of weird but the thing was the
Caption: rule is if you close your door you don't
Caption: want to be disturbed people can't stop
Caption: by people can't aren't supposed to knock
Caption: on the door and that's your headspace
Caption: that's you are time they also have this
Caption: weird thing where you can decorate
Caption: inside there any way you wish we're guys
Caption: that had like blacklight posters and
Caption: beanbag chairs and lots of other things
Caption: and there's not a lot of room I mean the
Caption: office is like maybe that big you know a
Caption: lot of them had standup desks or
Caption: whatever but they sort of understood
Caption: this notion of flywheel of making things
Caption: easier a great example of flywheel is
Caption: are things like continuous delivery and
Caption: continuous integration and I love this
Caption: quote from Jess humble about
Caption: incrementalism if it hurts do it more
Caption: often do it more frequently bring the
Caption: pain forward this is a really great
Caption: message from this continuous delivery
Caption: world a handful of customers I work with
Caption: are still in this notion where they
Caption: released a production four times a year
Caption: means you only got four shots in a year
Caption: to get it right and boy if you don't get
Caption: it right on one of them now you're you
Caption: kind of really screwed I think you have
Caption: to back everything up and a lot of
Caption: people are upset but if you do this kind
Caption: of continuous delivery experience if you
Caption: do this more often you can you can
Caption: actually you get 20 shots a year 25
Caption: shots a year if you're at sea you get 40
Caption: times a day
Caption: right so it's really amazing so what
Caption: happens is if you can just do a little
Caption: ink make it a little bit better then the
Caption: next time it's even easier to make it a
Caption: little bit better and a little bit
Caption: better and that's a lot of what
Caption: continuous delivery is about it's about
Caption: taking things in very very small chunks
Caption: to make it easy this is how John all
Caption: spot from Etsy actually explains this
Caption: notion of making it easy if you've only
Caption: got four times a year it's
Caption: big bet every single time we're gonna
Caption: tell people you can't go on vacation you
Caption: have to come in on the weekend it's
Caption: gonna be a really big thing because
Caption: we're in there's shot the old system
Caption: down Friday at midnight we're gonna have
Caption: it all back up and running by Saturday
Caption: and hopefully you have all day as Sunday
Caption: to fix the bugs and then everybody comes
Caption: in Lindy it's great and it's a huge
Caption: disruption of everyone's lives and the
Caption: thing is if it screws up you're really
Caption: kind of cooked for another couple of
Caption: months but if you do it in small
Caption: increments there are lots of advantages
Caption: so first of all every one of these big
Caption: packages packages maybe they have 150
Caption: changes in them mathematically that
Caption: means there's about eleven thousand
Caption: possible things that can go wrong just
Caption: inside that package not counting how it
Caption: affects everyone else right but if I can
Caption: make it a smaller package maybe there's
Caption: only ten things in it now there's only
Caption: about a hundred or so possible things
Caption: that can go wrong orders of magnitude
Caption: easier right so that's a big deal right
Caption: there so if something does go wrong I
Caption: have a decent shot at figuring out what
Caption: that is also if I have to back it out
Caption: it's easier if I have to back it out
Caption: fewer people are affected so I don't
Caption: have such a big blast radius I don't
Caption: have such a big disappointment so
Caption: there's lots of advantages to doing it
Caption: smaller it turns out I may not actually
Caption: get more done in a year this way but I
Caption: have a better likelihood of success I
Caption: have that flywheel effect and in fact it
Caption: turns out as jazz and and and Farley and
Caption: others talked about when they talk about
Caption: continuous delivery as you build up this
Caption: ability to do these in small pieces and
Caption: it gets easier and easier and easier and
Caption: easier and easier and pretty soon your
Caption: pace it's not just two weeks you can be
Caption: like Etsy you can actually do it
Caption: multiple times a day if you like so that
Caption: flywheel principle makes a lot of sense
Caption: there's this tremendous power in this
Caption: ability to do just a little bit every
Caption: single day
Caption: Tom and Mary poppendieck who brought
Caption: lean-to software have this idea and they
Caption: say if you had to change one line of
Caption: code in your system
Caption: how long before it shows up in
Caption: production
Caption: it's a day a week a month an hour
Caption: that's your agility that's your speed
Caption: that's your delivery speed right there
Caption: and if you can just shave a little bit
Caption: of time off of that that gets you closer
Caption: and closer to doing great things and
Caption: when the cost of change gets cheaper and
Caption: when the risk gets lower you're more
Caption: likely to try something different you're
Caption: more likely to try experiments that
Caption: might get you from that good to great
Caption: because it's not such a big risk anymore
Caption: it's not betting the company every time
Caption: you wanted to go into production so I've
Caption: talked about these principles and I've
Caption: talked about them sort of in these ways
Caption: of API companies and tech companies I
Caption: love that Spotify has this notion of
Caption: level 5 developers of how developers can
Caption: move up the ladder how Netflix focuses
Caption: on first getting the right people on the
Caption: bus before they worry about where
Caption: they're going how yeah he was able to
Caption: constantly confront the brutal facts and
Caption: actually get praised for it inside his
Caption: company and how Twilio has this notion
Caption: of really tapping into our passions and
Caption: how balance payments has this discipline
Caption: this idea that we can do the little
Caption: things and it makes a difference and how
Caption: Amazon is willing to try whatever
Caption: technology makes sense for it to get to
Caption: its goals and what it wants to do and
Caption: finally that Etsy teaches us so much
Caption: about how just incremental ISM little
Caption: bits of things help you reach a
Caption: greatness that you might not normally
Caption: get and I think these are just really
Caption: really powerful so I have a sort of a
Caption: Steve Jobs II one more thing kind of
Caption: deal for this remember this thing when
Caption: we talked about this this idea of of
Caption: capable and team members and managers
Caption: contributing and stuff like that
Caption: I thought about this and I said can I
Caption: directly translate that into a kind of
Caption: an API pyramid can I come up with level
Caption: five api's what would those be about
Caption: and my colleague Ronnie meter who works
Caption: in the API Academy has has done a lot of
Caption: research on usability and human-computer
Caption: interaction these other things and and
Caption: he has a lot of this so I'm gonna kind
Caption: of steal from some of the things that
Caption: he's taught me and kind of extend on it
Caption: a little bit so at sort of the level one
Caption: API you have a API that's functional it
Caption: works that's good it's ok a little a
Caption: little hard to use not so much fun I
Caption: can't believe they did it this way I
Caption: guess it works right we all have these
Caption: experiences where yes it's ok I really
Caption: prefer they did something else and you
Caption: can go beyond that just plain
Caption: functionality to something that is is
Caption: reliable it's not only does it work but
Caption: at least it's consistent and it works
Caption: all the time and it's it's it's pretty
Caption: effective
Caption: it's decent its it actually I feel
Caption: pretty good about this I am I have some
Caption: good confidence and if I feel a little
Caption: better about this even more importantly
Caption: I have an API that's easy to use it
Caption: isn't it isn't just functional it isn't
Caption: just reliable but it's pretty easy to
Caption: use it's actually hard to screw up with
Caption: this API right we all know products that
Caption: start that we just sort of say you know
Caption: what this product kind of understands me
Caption: this is exactly how I think this ought
Caption: to work we also know apps where we just
Caption: get really pissed like what do you mean
Caption: I just deleted all my contacts that
Caption: buttons too small you know we all have
Caption: these experiences and when we're working
Caption: inside an organization we're designing
Caption: api's for their our team members or for
Caption: partners or customers they have the same
Caption: experience with our API so like I can't
Caption: believe you made it so easy for me to
Caption: delete the database and there's no
Caption: backup there's no there's no undo and
Caption: past usable is actually present like
Caption: this is fun like I love doing this in
Caption: matter of fact I love it so much I'm
Caption: gonna tell my friends at the next Meetup
Caption: about this API that I use and that
Caption: starts to get really powerful for
Caption: suddenly now this API actually makes me
Caption: feel good
Caption: I like working with this that in fact I
Caption: think I want to learn more about this
Caption: language or more about this technology
Caption: because this is really interesting to me
Caption: and I'll start to share this with lots
Caption: of other people now I may I might even
Caption: get passionate about it but so even
Caption: beyond that is not only do I like doing
Caption: this but I've done a lot of this and
Caption: there's nobody that does this better
Caption: than that right so suddenly I'm creating
Caption: an API that nobody can do as well as we
Caption: can
Caption: I'm actually starting to turn this in
Caption: what in the world happen there I guess I
Caption: got an update that's a bad API so I like
Caption: this idea that there are there are
Caption: levels to this for a handful of reasons
Caption: we all start somewhere on this chart our
Caption: organization is always somewhere on this
Caption: chart and for most of us there's still a
Caption: lot of headroom there's still a lot of
Caption: opportunity and there's still a lot of
Caption: ways we can think about it and the way
Caption: Roni taught me this kind of thing about
Caption: usability and functionality and
Caption: experience is you're always thinking
Caption: about it from the users point of view
Caption: from helping them solve their problem
Caption: how do they feel about using it how do
Caption: they feel about using the work that I do
Caption: and I love that that really kind of
Caption: touches into that doing hard work and
Caption: being humble it's not about me but it's
Caption: about you so I think there's lots of
Caption: really cool things in this notion and
Caption: ways to think about this I'm gonna
Caption: mention I really love this book
Caption: designing for a motion by Erin Walker
Caption: Walter it's this idea about how do I get
Caption: beyond just something that's functional
Caption: but something that makes people feel II
Caption: feel really good
Caption: a lot of human-computer action is about
Caption: how we touch emotions how people feel
Caption: about what this is this is also becoming
Caption: a really big thing in the AI space or in
Caption: the bot space we talk about all these
Caption: things where people might feel kind of
Caption: creeped out about how computers start to
Caption: interact with us but sometimes we
Caption: actually feel pretty good we feel pretty
Caption: pretty pretty okay about this and it
Caption: actually it can be pleasurable so how
Caption: can we design for that how can we design
Caption: past just functional and usable into
Caption: that space where people really get
Caption: passionate and excited and this last
Caption: quote from Collins I'm gonna add because
Caption: I really like this quote
Caption: basically you can accomplish anything if
Caption: you don't care who gets credit and it
Caption: goes right back to Collins first thing
Caption: about how you want to work hard and be
Caption: humble and the challenge for me when I
Caption: when I travel is often the people I
Caption: would love to talk to more and more are
Caption: the people who have this kind of
Caption: attitude and often they're the ones
Caption: standing off to the corner there in the
Caption: back of the room they're not the ones up
Caption: in front of the room speaking they're
Caption: the humble ones so you have to look for
Caption: them and you probably have them in your
Caption: company you probably know who they are
Caption: who are the ones that work hard and are
Caption: humble and they probably have a lot to
Caption: teach all of us about how to turn
Caption: something from good to great and I hope
Caption: you can find those people inside your
Caption: organization and that you can start
Caption: doing that same thing so that's what I
Caption: have I want to thank you very much for
Caption: listening thanks
Caption: turn over to you do we have some time
Caption: for questions okay I'd be happy to
Caption: answer any questions about this or
Caption: possibly other things I don't want to
Caption: open it up and be responsible for
Caption: anything but is there any questions at
Caption: all I'd be happy to share comments maybe
Caption: you have examples explaining your own
Caption: experience about some of these these
Caption: things we talked about as well
Caption: anything anyone yes yeah so the question
Caption: was I talked about Amazon and how Amazon
Caption: kinda doesn't care too much about the
Caption: technology that you and your team ends
Caption: up using is that manageable how do they
Caption: deal with the variance and how do they
Caption: deal with with that the way they explain
Caption: it to us is they offer a sort of a set
Caption: of tools like a common way of doing
Caption: things and they allow the teams to make
Caption: their own decisions if they want to go
Caption: off-book if they want to do something
Caption: else there are some basic rules about
Caption: staying within the guardrails there's
Caption: some security checks or some other
Caption: things licensing issues but for the most
Caption: part they don't focus a lot about the
Caption: inside of a team as a matter of fact the
Caption: things we hear about Amazon is Amazon
Caption: teams are fairly black boxy you can't
Caption: really see too much inside a team they
Caption: might use a different language than
Caption: another team and so on and so forth so
Caption: they really govern that that that shared
Caption: understanding between parties or then
Caption: they do what happens inside the box the
Caption: line that Vernor Vogel's shares about
Caption: this whole idea is you built it you own
Caption: it so it's okay if you don't want to use
Caption: this stuff we suggest if you want to use
Caption: something else just know that you're the
Caption: one that's responsible so that's sort of
Caption: the way it the culture kind of works
Caption: there the impression that we get is that
Caption: it's pretty much a you know a very
Caption: competitive culture you're free to be as
Caption: creative as you want
Caption: you just have to make sure you produce
Caption: as expected and so that's pretty much
Caption: the pattern we're also told when we talk
Caption: to people there that there is lots of
Caption: actual duplication of things people will
Caption: fork things and have their own copy and
Caption: as long as they maintain their own copy
Caption: they don't care that there's lots of
Caption: duplication so that's just kind of the
Caption: culture that amazon has I would find
Caption: that pretty challenging to work in
Caption: myself I think I guess maybe at a team
Caption: level I'd like it but if I was
Caption: responsible for for understanding larger
Caption: bits of it it'd be kind of tough but I
Caption: think that just seems to be working well
Caption: for Amazon right now it's a good
Caption: question yes yeah if I understand it
Caption: it's like a lot of the things I talked
Caption: about we're very product oriented or
Caption: sort of solution oriented right and
Caption: which you're asking about is sort of
Caption: this idea of a problem domain space or
Caption: something that might not be the end
Caption: solution there's some other kind of
Caption: solution like CQRS solves a different
Caption: kind of problem is is that kind of the
Caption: way you're thinking about that sir yeah
Caption: yeah yeah so we can talk a little bit
Caption: about that sort of understanding the
Caption: problem before you start the solution a
Caption: lot of organizations that I that I end
Caption: up talking to most of the many of the
Caption: the parts of the system that they're
Caption: building
Caption: they don't actually understand the
Caption: problem that the final solution is
Caption: solving in other words they're actually
Caption: building infrastructure or framework for
Caption: other people to create solutions to
Caption: solve problems that's for example that's
Caption: really Amazon's motive right
Caption: at the same time each one of them has
Caption: their own responsibility for a domain
Caption: right so if our domain is data if our
Caption: domain is messaging if our domain is is
Caption: managing users or something we have our
Caption: own ubiquitous language we have our own
Caption: domain understanding that we have to be
Caption: consistent in so it's the sort of
Caption: coherence cohesion challenge right and a
Caption: thing like CQRS
Caption: turns out to be a technology that I can
Caption: use inside
Caption: solving that domain right so just
Caption: because I want to separate commands
Caption: inquiries and stuff like that is really
Caption: just a technological element to solving
Caption: the problem now if it turns out my job
Caption: is actually creating CQRS systems for
Caption: other to use that would become my
Caption: problem domain so I find it kind of
Caption: interesting that several of these
Caption: organizations have this notion of
Caption: creating building block systems in order
Caption: for somebody else to create solutions
Caption: for that means they're in a world where
Caption: they don't know the problem that they're
Caption: being used to solve now Netflix is not
Caption: like that Netflix has a shared
Caption: understanding from top to bottom they
Caption: have some people in the you know and the
Caption: baseline of the organization that do
Caption: things like we do operations we do
Caption: release we do data management but their
Caption: language of their business is pretty
Caption: simple at C's the same way Twilio is the
Caption: same way so making sure you you you sort
Caption: of have this idea of what our domain is
Caption: and and whether or not there's that
Caption: domain is just the all-encompassing one
Caption: or at some subset part is definitely
Caption: definitely can be a challenge what I
Caption: find really interesting is one of the
Caption: things that we're starting to see as
Caption: people are spending more time in this
Caption: smaller service space in this mornin
Caption: sort of context boundary space we
Caption: learned from a couple organizations is
Caption: it turns out that the boundaries change
Caption: over time it turns out that what made
Caption: sense to release in this clump probably
Caption: needs to be released in two clumps
Caption: because now we have to scale something
Caption: more than we did last time so it isn't
Caption: so much a one of the things that unless
Caption: Martin Fowler has pointed out and some
Caption: other people have pointed out is the
Caption: best way to do a great just context
Caption: boundary or great domain design is to
Caption: already know this there's no the design
Caption: and no the system before you actually
Caption: build this and that's really an example
Caption: of system 1 and system 2 from James from
Caption: Brooks this idea that the first system
Caption: you build you learn an awful lot it's
Caption: not always the best one so you build a
Caption: second one that's better
Caption: all right and we all experience this we
Caption: all experience rebuilds redesigns
Caption: so there's certainly that part of it but
Caption: I think what happens is there's also
Caption: system three and system four and system
Caption: five we learn from each release and I
Caption: think one of the things that that makes
Caption: sense is that's why incrementalism is so
Caption: powerful because I get to release
Caption: another one tomorrow I get to fix it a
Caption: little bit tomorrow hopefully that comes
Caption: close to what we're talking about yeah
Caption: others yes yes if I understand the
Caption: question the answer is yes so actually
Caption: Netflix does that right
Caption: Netflix designs their system based on
Caption: this idea of type 1 and type 2 safety do
Caption: we know this Eric hole Nagel who's kind
Caption: of a hero of the DevOps movement talks a
Caption: lot about route control or causes of
Caption: errors and that kind of thing
Caption: he actually works not just in the IT
Caption: space but with hospitals and nuclear
Caption: power plants how do you how do you make
Caption: them safe and there are two key forms of
Caption: doing this type one safety is I find all
Caption: the bugs and I remove them I spend the
Caption: effort to remove them and the type 2
Caption: safety is I remove as many as I can but
Caption: I add more into the system to survive
Caption: any bugs that I haven't found right so I
Caption: type 2 safety is I'm gonna survive
Caption: there's a line there's a book called
Caption: system antics system antics and I forget
Caption: the name of the author but one of the
Caption: quotes from that book is great systems
Caption: reliable systems continue to operate
Caption: even in failure mode so even when things
Caption: are failing they keep working and we
Caption: know lots of examples of this in real
Caption: life like airplanes right and nuclear
Caption: power plants and and a lot of times cars
Caption: and all sorts of other things they
Caption: continue to work even when parts of the
Caption: system go down go through it's
Caption: redundancy or some other thing like that
Caption: so there are lots of pretty good
Caption: examples of that and we definitely have
Caption: companies that focus on this idea
Caption: there's a great book by Michael Nygaard
Caption: Michael Nygaard is also going to be a
Caption: guest right for y'all Perth and he has a
Caption: book called release it name buddy seen
Caption: this book release it it's a great book
Caption: and he has this section in it about
Caption: basically releasable software needs to
Caption: be resilient software and he has a whole
Caption: section on what are called stability
Caption: patterns and capability yeah capability
Caption: patterns so stability patterns are
Caption: things like circuit breaker bulkhead
Caption: handshaking fail fast timeout
Caption: steady-state all these sort of patterns
Caption: to help you continue to work continue to
Caption: survive protect yourself from other
Caption: things as well as survive bugs from
Caption: other places or even bugs in your own
Caption: system well in the comments that Michael
Caption: makes in that book is that it turns out
Caption: you often spend more time coding for
Caption: resiliency than coding for functionality
Caption: right so here's a whole book that's
Caption: talks about how to do this he's actually
Caption: in that second edition right now so I
Caption: think especially those of us who are
Caption: starting to work in micro service space
Caption: where there there's more network there's
Caption: possibly more network time than there is
Caption: compute time in what we're doing then
Caption: we're also good doing this idea of
Caption: designing for failure
Caption: what's the not seem to lead book there's
Caption: a there's a book that's sort of based on
Caption: this what is it anti fragile right and
Caption: seem has an even sort of next-level way
Caption: of thinking about this and that is that
Caption: that ability to survive in in a bit of
Caption: chaos actually makes you stronger
Caption: actually makes you better you get to
Caption: learn from that so I I don't quite like
Caption: I don't know quite how to translate that
Caption: into IT but I know I'm pretty sure the
Caption: anti fragile book is the one that they
Caption: is one of them books they hand out at
Caption: Netflix to their new engineers so this
Caption: is definitely you're hitting on it like
Caption: a really important space it could be as
Caption: we start to get more AI to start
Caption: adjusting how things work together that
Caption: that's where that learning is that the
Caption: that that difficulty that friction that
Caption: trouble that
Caption: set of bugs actually strengthen systems
Caption: they learn how to kind of repair
Caption: themselves so that's that's another
Caption: possibility it's a good question
Caption: very good anything else we doing okay
Caption: yes all right well I just want to say
Caption: thank you very very much
Caption: I've had a great time and I'm gonna turn
Caption: it back over to Amy thank you thanks
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: that's right exactly
Caption: really actually I will be here through
Caption: Saturday so we'll have the workshop
Caption: tomorrow and then I get Friday off so I
Caption: think I'm gonna go to rottenness I think
Caption: get on the ferry pet something is that
Caption: what I'm supposed to do huh
Caption: Yeah right I'm supposed to do that right
Caption: and maybe yeah I get everything right
Caption: all right I'll do that insure it yep oh
Caption: yes I thought I would never do that
Caption: absolutely
Caption: Wow
Caption: one of my friends will have a good time
Caption: tomorrow midnight excellent thanks
Caption: thanks
Caption: [Applause]